[Music]
fiancee raining I'm in a raining over a
weekend two of the Coachella Music
Festival that is right queen bee did not
disappoint and I'm not just talking
about the performance we all know how I
feel about rhinestones it was all about
the costumes
which special guest J Balvin mrs. Carter
rocked five outfits all completely
different from last weekend we love this
sequined pullover she paired with thigh
high boots and this glittering cave and
massive headpiece were also everything
all were made custom again by ball ma
Beyonce flipped the script on this
yellow hoodie from weekend one
by simply turning it pink but the best
accessory her family hubby jay-z again
helping v-belt out there hit deja boo'
sister Solange also made it deja vu but
this time this Devlin's took a tumble
during their dance battle they Chell
around to Drew way more star superfans
Gabrielle Union helicoptered in Katie
Holmes and Octavia Spencer posted with
B's mom Tina and Tyler Perry is going
all the way and Jennifer Hudson she made
it a mini Dreamgirls reunion backstage
and hung out with Katy Perry and cardi B
on stage it was all about Destiny's
Child
again months of rigorous rehearsal each
costume change was strategic she would
be in rehearsal in one room then she'd
run over to the next room to see what
wardrobe is doing while trying to eat
almonds and oranges brilliantly involved
in every decision
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]